[Musique]
j'ai fait beaucoup de sport j'en ai
essayé plainte
c'est vraiment cacher vos patins que si
le salon com cliquer et feeling sondes
de vitesse pitot c'est ce que j'ai le
plus aimé
à doha sony 16 ans est en sport études
depuis le début de son secondaire comme
tous ses camarades de sport elle se plie
un horaire exigeant
l'école c'est toujours le matin donc de
85 à midi es10 des fois j'ai des
entraînements ici à trésors ou sinon
j'en ai à 17,1 ça dépend les heures à
chaque jour des fois j'ai dû vélo aussi
du fromage unis qui deux fois se mêler
de la musculation et six
en pleine croissance et pratiquant un
sport très énergivore l'alimentation des
adolescents sport-études n'est pas
laissé au hasard
qu'en pense un jeune en sport études ces
besoins sont comme doublé presse parce
qu'il ya besoin de croissance donc un
jeune adolescent est en croissance des
besoins plus élevé que la moyenne des
gens et on a un besoin accumulé de
charges d'entraînement donc des besoins
encore plus grand donc mixer les deux
ensemble des postes difficiles
d'atteindre
ses besoins énergétiques les dans la
journée si c'est pas organisé justement
[Musique]
marianne st gelais médaillée olympique
en courte piste entraîne le groupe des
draps
c'est normal à 17,1 de ne pas penser que
la nourriture salle un impact
nécessairement dans pense qu'ils vont
faire au quotidien séisme ne sais pas je
prend une gorgée d'eau je prends un
fruit tout de suite ça va paraître sur
la glace bon vive des cycles de où ils
vont être plus fatigués ou justement ils
vont sentir qu'ils ont moins d'énergie
ben ils vont comprendre justement que la
nutrition alors à leurs liens en fait
qui a le réellement un rôle à jouer dans
dans l'eure le côté performance par
exemple on est en manque d'énergie sur
la glace ou un exemple très près ce qui
arrive c'est très fréquent là qu'est ce
que tu as mangé avant abello on va se
rendre compte que finalement le dernier
rapport monte à 4 heures et l'autre cc
c'est un petit peu trop loin ou ou âgées
manger des frites avec un big up là je
veux je trouve que lourdes un peu je
fais des roues est un peu normal c'est
très très lourd en ce moment dans ton
estomac donc mangez pas trop longtemps
avant l'entraînement pas trop près non
plus sept membres de l'organisation
j'appartiens avec une boîte à lunch
assez complexe os que j'ai des
collations j'ai un linge et des
collations pour avoir mon entraînement
pendant mon entraînement après mon
entraînement possiblement qui des fois
on a des jeunes qui qu'on rajoute du
transport à ce donc une heure deux
heures de transport avant ou après
wasquehal j'ai peut-être manger des
collations aussi donc si je peux
planifié d'avoir toutes ces collations
le tout c'est leur jeu peut en effet
retrouvé arrivée à la maison à famille
puis manqué d'énergie manqué de
concentration à l'école lucie en juin
place davantage en planification au
niveau des menus
lorsqu'on a une athlète dans la famille
l'alimentation devient tout le travail
d'équipé je m'assure qu'il ya vraiment
une diversité à la fois dans le
garde-manger puis dans le frigo et dans
l'assiette aussi après les connaissances
plus points en dessous plus spécifique
c'est vraiment do ré que les ramener
est ce que vous trouvez que est leur
rapport sain à la nutrition et
l'alimentation
je pense que oui tout ce que je vois au
credo auprès d'ados race et le plaisir
qu'il prend à manger à composer son
assiette à cuisiner à se questionner par
rapport à ce que pourrait préparer à
prendre plaisir à cuisiner qui a mangé
ce qu'elle a fait mais aussi je pense
que chez quand même bonne pour la
nutrition c'est quand même quelque chose
qui s'y adapter avec le temps fait j'ai
jamais vraiment de misère avec ce que je
mange et je pense que j'ai quand même un
site capable de savoir quoi manger
comment j l'église c'est sûrement le mot
que je disais le plus souvent quand je
parle à des athlètes c'est vraiment
vraiment important que j'ai c'est de
défaire cette mentalité là que c'est
mauvais les 6 et démons
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça paie sur le corps les
glucides c'est l'énergie que les
musulmans utilisé pour performer donc
c'est l'énergie de choix pour performer
un hôte intense donc on en a besoin
c'est ce qui va me permettre justement
d'être capable de passer à travers mon
entraînement il faut savoir que les
cerveaux carrure uniquement aux glycines
donc ça peut être important aussi pour
la concentration à l'école forte
ressentie je mange des fruits comme et
des pommes la compote serment et
collations qu'il aime le plus j'ai eu
six barres tendres puis lee burke leaf
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a fait le plus
dur quand j ai failli dans les bus et le
système sait les fruits majoritairement
les féculents qu'on parle de fiction je
parle des produits céréaliers comme le
pain les pâtes les pommes de terre vont
entrer là dedans aussi aux légumes mais
c'est plus riches en glucides sans
équivoque aux maoris aux parts au
couscous chinois il ya les légumineuses
aussi qu'ils ont dégusté de dans les
produits laitiers comme le lait le yogo
vont donner des livres chez vous sinon
toutes ces aliments leur
devrait figurer dans le menu dans
l'athlète
transports étudie
les protéines joue également un rôle
très important dans le développement il
protège ceux ci plus la réparation issue
musculaire puis tout seul fax et surtout
si c'est mieux après un entraînement
comme vous considérez pas aussi mais ça
va aider à réparer les tissus
musculaires et protéines c'est important
pour la croissance la formation
musculaire on a besoin à chaque peuple
c'est aussi un enjeu qu'on remarque
c'est que des reports il y en a beaucoup
trop alors que des repas qui en manquent
vraiment donc de mieux répartir les
protège dressing si les deux grands
enjeux dans l'alimentation des actifs
chose certaine il ne sert à rien de
calculé les adolescents doivent garder
un rapport sain et avec l'alimentation
et manger à leur faim l'alimentation
c'est quelque chose qui devrait être
plus simple qu'on pense c'est des fois
on veut chercher la solution magique
mais juste avant une proportion qui fait
du sens dans l'assiette d'avoir des
aliments qui sont qui sont cinq qui sont
entiers du plutôt que d'acheter des
choses déjà tout fait ça peut juste être
simple
le but c'est vraiment de conscientiser
qu'ils prennent conscience ce qu'est ce
qu'ils mangent mais ça se transforme en
énergie
[Applaudissements]